SéSébastien Bovet, Michel C. Aur
bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Vous êtes pris avec moi pour
fifinir la saison de ce panel.
DaDans le fait pas de panel
dedemain. On fera une entrevue
avavec Christine St-Pierre, un
papanel américain sur ce qui se
papasse aux États-Unis.
PoPompiers à la produi que je
cocommence avec Sébastien. Maisn
écécoute le ministre qui dit que
lele rapport sur l'état du pont,
ququi ne l'avait pas vu jusqu'à
hihier.
FRFRANÇOIS BONNARDEL,
miministre des Transports
- - C'est certainement
ininacceptable que dans la chaîe
dede commandement, ce rapport at
étété déposé, dévoilé à certain,
cecertaines et au mois d'avril,
quque le cabinet politique
ouou moi-même n'ayons pas été
ininformés. Il faut comprendre
unune chose : je savais
ququ'il y avait eu consolidatio,
réréparation de certaines
sususpentes l'an passé, que
nonous avions une quarantaine
dede suspentes à consolider d'ii
lala fin de l'été, mais il est
ininconcevable que je n'aie pas
étété informé de ce rapport.
EtEt je veux rassurer les gens
ququi nous écoutent ce soir :
lele pont Pierre-Laporte
esest sécuritaire.
- - Quand les ingénieurs étaient
sosortis début mai en conférence
dede presse, ils sont en
nénégociations difficiles avec e
gogouvernement en disant : on je
avavec la série des ans parce qe
lele pompier à la porte n'est ps
sésécuritaire. Le lendemain le Q
esest sorti en disant: non, tout
vava bien. Or, c'est le 5 mai qe
lele ministère sort.
LeLe 21 avril Sébastien, on
dédéposera pas. Comment souhaite
quque c'est perdu?
- - Ce que je comprends cet être
mumusical au MTQ entre la
didirection générale et ceux qui
fofont les versions. Cette chice
a a fait en sorte que le rapport
n'n'est pas remonté rapidement u
cacabinet du ministre.
IlIl y a deux questions : le
prpremier c'est le pompier à la
poporte et il sécuritaire?
LaLa réponse du gouvernement c't
quque c'est oui. Je ne peux pas
crcroire qu'il dise autre chose
quque la vérité sur la COD du
popompier à la porte. La deuxièe
ququestion, c'est que ça se pase
auau ministère des Transports pr
quque ce rapport ne remonte pas?
IlIls y a des ministres des sou-
miministre qui vont dire que le
sosous-ministre le disent : pas
bebesoin de savoir. Mais le
miministre de transport doit
sasavoir les points les plus
imimportants au Québec. Il y a 5
0 000 qui passent chaque jour.
- - Peut-être que ces rapport et
unun peu alarmiste. Il ne dit ps
quque le pont va tomber mais des
quque un détachement de câble et
fofort possible Rick Hillier
auaurait certainement une versin
enen cascade. Alors que le
miministère saute tout.
- - Est-ce que le ministre
BoBonnardel aurait rendu publice
rarapport s'il avait eu quelques
sesemaines où il aurait gardé pr
lului? Au fait preuve de
trtransparence. Il faut dire les
chchoses telles qu'elles sont. l
fafait du rattrapage, mais la
ststructure en principe ne va ps
s's'écouler. En même temps
rarappeler voulait viaduc, de la
CoConcorde qui s'est effondrée,a
cocommission Johnson avait
rerecommandé l'inspepection de s
leles viaduc au Québec. Il en a
ququi manquait d'amour. Le MTQ a
papas une historique reluisante.
CÇa peut changer depuis quelques
anannées. Mais jusqu'à preuve du
cocontraire fait confiance.
- - Michel C. Auger c'est quand
mmême étonnant qu'il n'y ait pas
dede graphiques à l'appui et de
babaguette pour présenter les
chchoses du ministre, des sous-
miministre à côté. Conférence de
prpresse, voici, vous avez enteu
cececi cela la télé voici les
fafaits, voici l'échéancier.
LoLorsqu'on fait une entrevue pr
lala porte arrière, un attrait,a
fafait désordre, Michel non?
- - Ça fait beaucoup des autres.
CoComment voulez-vous que les
cicitoyens se sont à l'aise, en
sésécurité et même si je ne doue
papas que je suis d'accord avec
SéSébastien que le gouvernemente
mementirait pas là-dessus,  quad
lele ministre dit: je l'ai pas e
rarapport mais j'aurais dû lavo.
QuQui dans la soute du mécénat
trtransport qu'à affaires?
EtEt à un moment donné, il y a
efeffectivement dans ce rapport,
jeje ne suis pas ingénieur maisl
y y a des choses troublantes y
cocomprit le fait que les câbles
popourraient lâcher les uns aprs
leles autres, en série.
IlIl faut rassurer les gens et
jujuste dit...
- - avec des faits.
- - Avec des faits pararce que à
quque voulez-vous, les gens
pepeuvent ne pas avoir confiance
etet on peut les comprendre.
- - Il y a des négociations avec
leles ingénieurs et François
LeLegault à commencer par ça en
didisant qu'il faut qu'il y ait
unune négociation difficile avec
leles États-Unis. Les ingénieurs
onont des raisons habilités.
IlIl ne produirait pas, on
l'l'espère, un rapport inquiétat
ouou alarmiste pour une simple
raraison de négociation. Façon
ririgoureuse et de façon
prprofessionnelle. Est-ce que la
nénégociation vient teinter le
rarapport? Est-ce que la
nénégociation fasse en sorte que
lele rapport soit fut trompeuse
popour la question.
- - Peut-être mais comme vous le
ddîtes n'est pas la climat de
nénégo qui a fait écrit à un
iningénieur le fond du rapport.
- - Ce qui est troublant Patric,
c'c'est que l'ingénieur
reresponsable du la porte pompir
l'l'apprenant passera profil ça
c'c'est fatiguant. À la rigueur
ququi ne soit pas rendue au
miministre, de deux choses on pt
didire qu'on n'a pas vu le
miministre, l'ingénieur
reresponsable du pont, n'a pas
rereçu ça c'est incompréhensible
- - pour parler à Marie-Pierre,
esest-elle exagérée. Le ministre
dedevrait demander un autre avi,
pepeut-être qu'on nous expose tt
çaça. Comme mettre sur la table.
- - Monsieur Bonnardel donne
prpresque raison assez ingénieux
nonon seul d'alerte. Et dès qu'n
vava changer tout ça mais je vex
quque ça se fasse plus vite que
prprévu.
- - Fin de session à Ottawa la
sesemaine prochaine mais je veux
cocommencer... ça faisait désore
lele fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu e
coconférence de presse précise,
fafactuel et destiné à des
grgraphiques. Les patois c'est a
leles passepor c'est quand mêmea
LeLes passeports c'est la même
chchose. On dirait qu'Ottawa est
dédébordé et que les
adadministrations des provinces
ququi peuvent critiquer par
aiailleurs ... la liaison peut
fafaire mieux. Les passeports ça
vava rester comme une tâche.
- - C'est extraordinaire. On sot
d'd'une pandémie pendant laquele
onon ne pouvait pas voyager et s
papasseports sont échus. Mais nn
pepeut voyager avec faut beaucop
d'd'imagination pour comprendre
quque beaucoup de gens ne peuvet
papas voir leur passeport. Et on
pepeut fait la liste de toutes
sosortes de choses. Si on fait n
chchapeau sur tout ce qui sort u
bbêlement fédéral. Quand Madame
FrFreeland dit qu'il n'y a pas e
mumusique tout accorde, c'est qe
lele gouvernement ne doit pas...
etet ne sont pas voir la a beson
d'd'intervenir, la Ayaka Suzukie
vava pas, ce n'est pas normal qe
leles gens ne puissent avoir le
papasseport.
IlIl y a beaucoup d'autres
exexemples. Des diplomates qui
vovont à l'ambassade de Russie.
- - J'allais vous en parler mais
rerestons sur cet exemple.
SéSébastien, l'affaire des
papasseports, bien sûr que la
dedemande a augmenté, on compred
çaça mais on ne comprend pas ces
nene se soit pas davantage prépé
enen amont?
- - Et fédéral Madame Goodall a
adadmis. La pas vu venir et ils
auauraient dû le voir venir. Pae
quque les gens voudraient voyagr
unune fois que les mesures
sasanitaires est tombé. Je sais
pas si on n'y aimait c'est comme
sisi le gouvernement de Justin
TrTrudeau est conforté dans sa
susurvie depuis l'entente avec e
NPNPD. Plutôt que d'être
gogouvernement minoritaire, ilse
sese sont pas si menacés que ça.
CÇa les a confortés dans le suii
dadans les prochaines années.
C'C'est terre-à-terre ce genre e
seservice. On s'attend ce que ça
fofonctionne quand on a besoin u
gogouvernement. Dans ce cas-ci n
vovoit que les gens passent
enensuite pour avoir le passepo.
- - Une autre hypothèse, il y ae
fafait que depuis plusieurs
anannées, tout est concentré das
lele bureau du premier ministre
enencore plus que jamais alors
ququ'il a dit qu'il ne ferait p.
IlIl a une concentration, commei
unune machine administrative avt
peperdu le sens de l'initiative
paparce qu'ils attendent notre
popolitique. Je pense que c'est
l'l'ancien greffier, Michel C,
MoMonsieur Tellier disait que
MoMonsieur Trudeau paralyse la
mamachine de ce pays parce qu'il
veveut décide de tout Michel?
- - Les fonctionnaires ont peure
sese faire rabrouer. Des
ininitiatives. C'est la théorieu
pipilote automatique et il y a e
chchose qui est importante,
SéSébastien y a fait allusion, s
n'n'ont plus de raisonon de penr
quque le gouvernement pourrait
totomber. On ne sait pas ce quee
prpremier ministre veut faire.
AuAu Canada... il est important
popour la machine, pour le
gogouvernement et ses députés
avavoir une idée d'où le premier
miministre ealler de ce qu'il
fafaire. Quand on est dans cette
dedeux fois artistique, ça des
esespèces suit la machine, et sr
lele ministre. Madame Freeland
d'd'aujourd'hui annonce un
didiscours important à Toronto.
ElElle est arrivée et elle dit :
susur l'inflation tout va bienÇa
vava bien merci bonsoir.
C'C'est dans ce dossier, d'foie
plplus petit que ce que Madame
FrFreeland dit.
OnOn dirait qui a une espèce de
blblocage à Ottawa.
- - Ils ne sont pas capables de
gégérer les passeports. C'est un
exexemple les passeports, très
teterre-à-terre et qui fait en
sosorte qu'on peut se poser la
ququestion sur la façon dont
lelesaffaires.
- - Michel vous lisiez plus que
momoi la presse internationale,
esest-ce que dans les pays de
l'l'OCDE qui ont ouvert aussi le
lala frontière, est-ce que on et
lele seul pays où difficile
d'd'avoir un renouvellement de
papasseport avant un voyage? Es-
cece que ça marche aux États-Un,
enen Italie, en France? Enfonça
pepeut-être non mais est-ce qu'n
esest le canard boiteux à ce sut
lala?
- - S'il y avait des problèmes n
ItItalie ou ailleurs avec des gs
ququi comme de pour avoir un
papasseport, ça se saurait. On
l'l'aurait vu mais moi je l'ai s
vuvu. Peut-être que la journée e
veveulent pas parler détente à
l'l'extérieur des bureaux de
papasseport...
- - très bien. Merci je vous
reremercie. Il me reste le temps
dede vous remercier pour ce panl
etet pour tous les autres. Pour